problem 47 which graph represents the
system of equations shown below so each
of these equations represents a line so
this is going to be a line that well
both of them have y-intercepts of +3 and
then this line has a slope of minus 1 so
let's see we need a downward sloping
thing that intersects at positive 3
actually they're both they're both going
to intersect at positive 3 so choice a
neither of them they in choice a both of
their y-intercepts are minus 3 we need
to see a plus 3 here so it's not choice
a in choice C one of the lines
intersects at positive 3 but the other
line intersects at minus 3 and there
also have the same slope and these guys
obviously don't have the same slope so
it's not going to be choice C C choice B
so I have two lines both of them have a
y-intercept of 3 this looks good so far
both of them have y-intercepts of 3 and
then I have one line that has a positive
slope of 1 for every one I go over I go
up one and I have one that has a
negative slope of 1 so down what when I
move over 1 I go down 1 so this line
right here is y is equal to X because it
has a slope of 1 1 X plus 3 3 is its
y-intercept and this line right here is
y is equal to its slope is minus 1 you
move to the right one you go down 1 so
minus 1 X or minus X and its y-intercept
is plus 3 so our answer is B these are
the two equations that we have that we
have up there that we got to conceive
yet that we have right here our answer
is B and D both of these guys have the
same slope so you can't have the you
know clearly doesn't apply to the two
equations up there and they also have
two different y-intercepts so it's
definitely not choice D definitely not
choice D all right problem 48 Yoshi has
exactly $1 in dimes which is 10 cents
and nickels 5 cents all right if Yoshi
has twice as many dimes as nickels
how many nickels
does she have so has $1 so let's n equal
the number of nickels nickels and let D
is equal to the number of dimes the not
dimes so it says yo she has twice as
many dimes as nickels so the dimes are
twice as many the number of nickels
that's what this tells us vo she has
twice as many dimes as nickels that
translates into the dimes are two times
the nickels and then we also know that
she has one dollar so how do you get one
dollar well it's 10 cents times so 0.1
times the number of dimes or we may pass
a point 10 times the number of dimes
plus 0.05 times the number of nickels is
equal to one dollar or maybe just so we
can avoid decimals I could rewrite this
statement right here exactly one dollar
instead of writing in dollars I could
write it in cents
I could write ten cents times each dime
plus five cents times each nickel is
equal to 100 cents so if you if you
compare this equation in this equation I
just multiplied both sides by 100 here
I'm dealing with cents so one dollar is
100 cents here I'm dealing with dollars
a dime is 1/10 of a dollar a dime is ten
cents this one right here is probably a
little bit easier to deal with so what
are they asking how many nickels does
she have so we want to solve for n we
want to solve for nickels we have this
piece of information right here the
dimes are equal to two times the number
of nickels and we have this right here
so we can do a substitute for D we can
replace this D and we know that D is
equal to 2n so we could put 2n in the
place of that so let me write it over
here so I have 10 D plus 5 n is equal to
110 cents times my number of dimes plus
5 cents times my number nickels is equal
to 100 cents and then my dimes is equal
to 2n so 10 times 2n plus 5n
is equal to 110 times 2n is just 20 n +
5 n is equal to 100 and then we get 25 n
is equal to 100 divide both sides of
this equation by 25 and you get n is
equal to 100 divided by 25 is 4
Yoshi has 4 nickels 4 nickels and if you
want to know how many dimes you multiply
it by 2 she has eight dimes so she has
80 cents and dimes and then she has 20
cents in nickels 4 times 5 problem 49
what are all the possible values of x
such that 10 times the absolute value of
x is equal to 2.5 so we could simplify
this so we have 10 times the absolute
value of X is equal to 2.5 or if we
divide both sides of this equation by 10
we get let me do it in blue we get the
absolute value of x is equal to what's 2
point 5 divided by 10 2 point 5 divided
by 10 you might be able to just do it in
your head you say oh you know there's
four quarters in a dollar or 25 times 4
is 100 but you know this is 25 divided
by 10 if you're multiply two and a half
times 4 you're going to get 10 so you
could say this is 1/4 if that wasn't
obvious to you could actually do the
division you can divide 10 in to 2.5
maybe throw some zeroes there put the
decimal there 10 goes into 2 0 times 0
times 10 is 0 bring down the 2 2 minus 0
is 2 bring down the 5 10 goes into 25
how many times 10 goes into 25 goes into
25 2 times 2 times 10 is 20 25 minus 20
is 5 bring down another 0 10 goes into
50 exactly 5 times 5 times 10 is 50
subtract you get zero so 10 goes into
2.5 0.25 times which is the same thing
as 1/4
so it's point two-five the absolute
value of X is equal to 0.25 now that
tells us that X what are the two values
for X X could be X could definitely be
equal to 0.25 because the absolute value
of 0.25 is 0.25 or what other number
when I take its absolute value is 0.25
well it could be minus 0.25 I think the
absolute value of minus 2.25 i also get
0.25 so my two choices are 0.25 or minus
0.25 and that is choice a right there
and when we did this division I did it
kind of the long and slow way and if you
didn't recognize it this is 1/4 the
other way to say is when you divide by
10 that's equivalent to moving your
decimal one plot to the left so you
could say you could have just said oh 2
point 5 divided by 10 is equal to let's
just move the decimal over to the left
is equal to 0.25 all of those would have
been equivalent ways of doing it problem
50 which of the following is equivalent
to 1 minus 2x is greater than 3 times X
minus 2's let's solve this so we have 1
minus 2x is greater than 3 times X minus
2 or we get 1 minus 2x is greater than
let's distribute our 3 3x minus 6 3
times minus 2 is minus 6 now let's see
we can subtract 1 from both sides so we
have a minus 1 plus here I'm going to
subtract a 1 from that side and Ida
whole reason why I'm doing that is to
cancel out that one right there so this
side deals cancel out so I'm just left
with minus 2x is greater than 3x and
then minus 6 minus 1 is minus 7 and now
here is the vaguely tricky tricky part
well actually we're not at the vaguely
tricky part yet let's subtract 3x from
both sides so we have minus 3x on that
side and then minus 3x on that side and
the whole reason why I'm doing that the
whole reason why I wanted to do that is
to cancel out this 3x so that these two
guys obviously cancel out and I have
minus 3x plus -2 X which is minus 5x
is greater than minus seven and now here
is the vaguely tricky part we want to
divide both sides by minus five but when
you have an inequality and you're
dividing or multiplying both sides by a
negative number you need to switch the
inequality so then this M so this if we
divide both sides by minus five so I can
multiply by the fraction minus one-fifth
times minus five X and I'm going to have
a minus seven x minus one-fifth I'm
going to switch the inequality so it
goes from greater than to less than and
the whole reason why it's switched is
because I'm multiplying both sides or
you depending how you view it dividing
both sides by a negative number so then
this becomes I picked minus one-fifth so
this cancels out so this just becomes X
is less than and then minus seven times
minus one-fifth the negatives cancel out
or a mine at negative times a negative
is a positive so you're left with seven
fifths so X is less than seven fifths
and it shows you that maybe you don't
want to go work out the whole problem
because right here they didn't expect me
to figure out the whole problem so I
just wasted a little bit of both of our
time they just wanted us to go a couple
of steps into it so what did I just do
well they just wanted that first step
where I multiplied it where I
distributed the three three X minus
three X minus six so that's all they did
here because they didn't change the
left-hand side anywhere they didn't
change the inequality anywhere so all I
had to do is pick choice see right there
but hopefully you learned a little bit
about inequalities as well I hate to
waste your time like that but this was
actually a fairly straightforward
problem they actually the very first
step we did got us to the answer so that
that teaches us both the lesson look at
the choices before you proceed with the
problem 5151 which equation represents
the line on the graph below so we could
look at this we could look at this we
can just kind of eyeball it but
sometimes is hard to eyeball it so what
we want to do is look for some points
you know my first intuition is say okay
y is equal to MX plus B let's look for
the y intercept and the slope but here
y-intercept it's not completely obvious
where it is although I could you know it
looks like it's at one and a half and we
could actually verify that it's at one
and a half because its slope its slope
you can see right here if we start at
one and if we go to to the right we go
down by exactly one so it's slope its
slope M is equal to change in Y over
change in X their change in Y when your
change in X is positive two your change
in Y is minus one so your slope is minus
one half so if you if you go back one
you're going to go up one half just like
that so our y-intercept is one and a
half it's right there is equal to one
point five just like that I can verify
that from the slope if I so if I you
know if I start at two and I go one to
the right that means I'm going to go one
half down because my slope is minus one
a so I'm going to go one half down and
that will get me to one and a half so
the equation of this line the equation
of this line is y is equal to minus
one-half X that's my slope plus one and
a half plus one and a half and that
doesn't look like any of these choices
here so we need to simplify this a
little bit well the first thing we might
want to do is multiply both sides of
this equation by two so you get two Y is
equal to two x minus 1/2 X is just minus
X and then two times one and a half is
three plus three and then if we add X to
both sides of this equation and I'm
doing that to get rid of this minus X on
the right hand side we get X plus 2y is
equal to three and that is choice a
right there which was completely
equivalent to what we did up here